like okay we'll talk about last night
okay right you get this [__] drus and
like we live in this world now where
people just could say whatever the [__]
they want and I don't think that helps
people get like hard right so it's like
I could go online right now I go on the
interwebs and I could start telling you
go [__] yourself [__] your mother [__]
your girlfriend [__] you and any kind of
recourse that you
do you'll go you'll get in trouble for
like right now I mean you don't got a
girlfriend or anything right just you
got a girlfriend I don't have a
girlfriend but I met your girlfriend at
SL yeah really sweet girl right but they
just say right now you had a girlfriend
or someone you loved I can get up right
now be like hey you know you know blah
blah blah she's a [__] this and that
and you technically can't do anything to
me and if you do something to me you
will go to prison right so you take drus
you know we get in this like we get in
this [__] heated fight you know he
heated press conference he starts
talking about like child abuse and like
yeah you know your dad [__] you like
again you
guys dad didn't [__] me that didn't ever
[__] happen you guys you know I mean
we all have some bad memories but we
just all we chalk him up as bad dreams
and we just move on from there you know
yeah or yeah but yeah if he didn't but
you know but it regardless of the fact
it's like so then I get put in the spot
where like you have this man next to me
when you jump back so after the D when
the dupus thing what's going on your
head you're like that you think about
the stuff he said yesterday you're like
I'm going to go say something well no it
was just more that he said let's fight
like right now wait he said it from
right then yeah so you heard him say
let's fight and then I you know you know
Gilbert Burns he has a lovely family bro
nobody's more fun to watch watch watch
the fights than watching Gilbert's
family it is the most there should be a
live stream just on them watching the
fight [__] the UFC [__] the UFC they
know that I'm stable they know that I
like every time the UFC asked me to go
to an event I'm like you guys you know
what like they'll ask me to go like look
at his family though like they ask me to
go hang out with kid rocket some [__]
that's not going to end well yeah and
I'm like yeah know it's just better it's
just better if I don't leave my house
house like it's not like you're putting
me in a bad situation yeah so they knew
that they knew what they were [__]
doing they put me in a bad situation do
you think they did it on purpose though
I don't I think they did it because they
wanted a shot but I didn't think they I
don't know if they thought it would go
that far right CU Dana said that it was
his fault well they did though they put
kids behind me so they're smart like
know what we're going to do we're going
to put some we're going to put some
[__] little little little we Lads
behind Shawn and the and the coach
[__] right but but here's the crazy
part though look at you here you go Sean
right there
now was this stage did you guys act this
out backstage or anything no no it's all
real and then he just sits there run his
[__] mouth dude he just run his
[__] mouth is he saying stuff to you
yeah he's like he's like saying look at
me like [__] you and then you know I
just kindly asked the
wife did you feel like you got any good
licks on him or no oh I land some good
12 to six elbows he seemed totally fine
when I saw him but is well this [__]
guy the just telling you I'm not judging
I don't I'm not a referee you know but I
wouldn't have stepped in oh yeah yeah
that's good you're not trying to get on
his dick right Keith Peterson's my
favorite referee dude is that oh the
black guy just let [__] go huh he just
let [__] go dude he's white I mean he
has enough neck tats where he [__] oh
yeah that guy the [__] little
Leprechaun yeah he's a good dude oh come
on my God he's a [__] Legend dude he
used to playing a rock band dude and
like when I went attack Dr I wasn't
angry when I went joyful oh I I want I
was more than happy seemed like a
Christmas attack like that's the only
thing that made me happy I'm like I
remember sitting there like as like I
mean cuz once like [__] he started
tackling me I started dropping like
these 12:00 elbows you will get a s
feeling yeah well that was so [__] up
too and I'm so happy they didn't get it
from a right
angle I bit him uh I [__] you not so I
whenever he went into me and I remember
like at that moment like you you'll
watch he's handsome yeah now he's a good
looking dude so at this moment he
tackles me watching you'll
see right there I started thinking you
see my head goes up towards it I started
thinking like how could I hurt this man
I'm G to take a [__] chunk out I'm
gonna bite his [__] ear off yeah and
it goes in the day and then I remember
like telling myself at that moment like
Sean you can't do that that's something
you can't walk away from like if you do
that right you're going over another
line if I go that then I'm going to jail
then I'm going to ja you're cannibal
then I'm a [__] cannibal yeah you don't
want to be that like look Sean we'll
accept certain things here okay you know
so like whenever you like that's scary
cuz you don't know like that line must
be so I just don't leave I don't leave
my house dude so it's like he he's able
to speak to me in a
way that in all of human all of human
history not even just America you would
never speak to a [__] man that way
you would never [__] do it but what
we have done dude we have made people so
pathetic that we just sit there and say
yeah say whatever you want say whatever
you want I'm just gonna [__] take it
I'm just going to take it like [__] it
dude like America is one of the softest
[__] in the world well a lot of
it I think you so then I think you're
probably talking about like civil law
like everything has become a law suit
you're going to get [__] sued you're
going to go to jail you know yeah like
when I was a kid I know that if you said
something that was [__] up somebody
would [__] you up you know like here's
how you knew you couldn't say the n-word
because you would say it and then you
get [__] up yeah you get [__] up
there wasn't like some big system online
that would judge you whatever you knew
now if you had a mixed buddy he might
let you slip it in after midnight or
something but if you were just a you
know you know every now and then there
might be a phrase that you say you're
like oh [__] my bad yeah like hey let me
you know hey look give me a s I need to
pass on that one yeah hey man it's leap
here let me get one in you know but like
so I'm I'm at this press conference
right and he's like talking about like
child mestation child abuse I saw it
yeah like and here I am dude like now if
now I'm in this weird position where I
can't defend myself because say like say
I'm like hey [__] you man like my dad
never [__] me but I'm gonna come put
my if I if I would have followed up with
it now what am I doing I I'm pretty much
saying that like what you said by joking
about like being abused or molested like
you I'm somehow a weaker man for that
the fact that that again didn't happen
to me but if it did happen to me I'm a
weaker man so by me being a defensive
and like clapping back and going back
now it's
like there's some things that were off
limits you know you don't really talk
about a man's wife yeah you don't really
you know you don't talk about a man's
wife you don't talk about a man's kids
and you don't talk about like [__] a
kid being abused these things were all
off limits and dude like once he crossed
that it was like and so was that the
energy that was there whenever you guys
were in
this I tried to ignore it I tried to
[__] ignore it D were you sitting
there thinking throughout the evening a
little bit like oh yeah I was I was
boiling dude I was just I just told
myself like hey just I [__] hate that
boy I hate that boil yeah I just I'm
just saying there like you see I'm just
seeing that I'm just ignore it just
[__] ignore it and he just St talking
[__] I'm like all right [__] this guy
but when you say ignore it was there
already that voice some of that REM oh
yeah you have voice in your head like
kill this man and this is what like this
is what people don't understand like
that's a crazy voice I'm not just saying
oh dud I've like dude I have like I
don't know if it's like I have that
voice dude yeah like oh it's bad I mean
I'll go like 120 and a [__] 30 mile
per hour like I I have that voice is
such an extreme yeah but you know it's
like it annoys but if it didn't even
happen why did it hurt you so much
though I think it was just the ability
that he can say that people can say the
fact that you can say that with impunity
and then it's kind of a weird situation
man cuz like I got a I got a big deep
fan base and like we all we all got
[__] up as you know we've all gone
most of us have gone through [__] right
I mean I could tell you how many guys do
I know that have been molested that's I
mean I know a lot oh yeah I know a lot
of [__] a lot of men who've been
molested I know more women who talk
about it but I know a lot of guys and
like you know my you know 2 am hits are
just bullshitting with like hey man Sean
like when I was this age just happen
like [__] dude I know now my bad dude so
to have this [__] like make a joke
about that yeah but you know but this is
the issue dude man like back in the day
like there were some repercussions there
and there still would be there would
still be if draus like again like why
didn't they take dupus out I fck I don't
he was the one that called me out he was
one to try to fight me he did it and
because here's what's funny is I'm I'm
leaving after the show last night and uh
and he's in the back right I started
talking I didn't know that that that
that that that that was him right I I I
remember that there was a South African
guy dude I think his coach might [__]
him actually hey pulled up show up show
show the
man what's the coach's name Ron yeah
just type in coach kissing drus or
grabbing his dick I mean it should be
one of the first things that comes up
but now some of this is a cultural thing
buddy I don't know dude you get your
dick grabbed a lot in South
Africa that could be made up
huh could be made up what about what
about do the wow he's strong guy huh
yeah he's in there dude he's in there
[__] I I think you know I wouldn't kiss
him but I would [__] i' i' get close
Toby grab we give a little little nut
grab no I'm not touching somebody's
[__] nuts that's insane whoaa that's
not okay that's crazy dude Ian that's an
Embrace though bro he seems like a very
nice guy I um but I didn't know that was
I didn't I don't think that that's
him